lors d'un rare déplacement hors de kiev
le président ukrainien volodimir
zelensky décor les troupes basées à
odessa cette ville portuaire clés du sud
du pays est à l'arrêt depuis le blocus
russe de la mer noire le chef de l'état
s'est aussi rendu à nikolaïev pour
soutenir les troupes sur la ligne de
front
je remercie chacun d'entre vous pour
votre travail votre engagement
pour ce que vous faites en protégeant le
pays chacun d'entre nous et nos familles
ici les forces ukrainiennes ont réussi à
repousser les assauts ennemis mais la
ville est régulièrement la cible de
frappes russe vendredi deux personnes
sont mortes et 20 autres ont été
blessées lors de bombardements
à plusieurs centaines de kilomètres de
là à les hitchens dans le donbass les
attaques sont incessantes ses habitants
sont en deuil après la mort de leurs
voisins tués par une roquette
il était gravement blessé on a couru
vers lui il a respiré pendant 2 minutes
puis a rendu son dernier souffle on n'a
rien pu faire
pour l'heure les ukrainiens contrôlent
toujours la ville mais les habitants eux
évacue la russie concentre ses frappes
sur les hits chantre et severodonezk
deux poches de résistance dans la région
de lougansk selon le gouverneur de la
région moscou envoie un grand nombre de
réservistes vers severodonetsk depuis
d'autres zones de combat pour assujettir
entièrement la ville dont la plupart est
déjà sous contrôle des forces heureux